all right medicare open enrollment is in
session if you didn't know and the
senior health care service has
a hometown advantage here's more
information
[Music]
so we're talking about senior medicare
advantage plans because that's
important now more than ever right it's
that time of year again i mean
october 15th through december 7th is the
time to go out and look for those plans
find out what changed with your current
plan and get ready to go forward with
the next one
so it's really that time to go out check
that mailbox make sure you get your
annual notice
of change and look to see what's out
there uh and how do they look to see
what's out there what do people need to
know
about these 20 20 plans there's many
different ways to look and see what's
out there one you can go
and talk to a broker or agent in the
area those brokers and agents are
experts in the field they can help you
narrow down plans that fit your needs
and get you plans with more benefits
than the plan you currently have
another way to go and look is to go to
medicare's website
which is medicare.gov you can go on that
website
type in your address or your zip code
put your medications in and it'll bring
up a list of plans that
cover your medications and show you
which plan is cheapest for you
there you go you make it convenient and
easy for everybody because these things
get complicated
um what are some of the benefits in
becoming a senior care plus
medicare advantage plan member
specifically
plus is the oldest medicare advantage
plan in the state of nevada
we've been around since 1995 as a
medicare plus choice plan
and we offer best-in-class customer
service
so we're a local plant we're a
not-for-profit we're domiciled right
here in the state of nevada
so your advantages to getting a senior
care plus membership are
being able to walk in and talk to
somebody in an office being able to call
up talk to a real nevadan and get your
questions answered you're not going to
be transferred around
a whole bunch of places you're going to
be able to get your questions answered
first off all right and tell us more
about your partnership with care more
health
we're very excited to introduce a senior
care plus plan two plans actually with
care more health
here in clark county care more health
has a long-standing
ability to deliver care that goes over
and above your normal primary care
doctor
you're still going to have your primary
care doctor but you're going to have a
wrap around care
that doesn't have a time limit on it
you're not going to be rushed to take
care of that
they're going to come in and encompass
all of your care needs
if you're a regular medicare advantage
member we have plans where
you can utilize in our network our
customer service and caremoors care
centers
and if you have a special need such as
copd
or congestive heart failure or diabetes
we have special plans
that give extra benefits to make sure
that you're taken care of with the care
more system
all right cj thank you so much for your
service and what you're giving our
seniors around the community any final
thoughts um
you know as people get into the open
enrollment period the most important
thing is to really go out there and look
there's
56 plans available in clark county now
that's a lot of information to absorb
so go talk to somebody you can go to our
websites you can call our phone number
but make sure you go out there and shop
this year because there could be a plan
out there
that has more benefits or better
benefits that you're looking for
for more information call 775-982-3158
or just visit seniorcareplus.com we'll
be right back